i hate intros hi q to the top ova one
and if you don't care about the ovas
because it's just fukurodani and nekoma
hai and how they qualified for the
nationals then you could jump ahead to
episode one
like i said before the first ova kicks
off with the qualifiers going on for
nationals
in the tokyo region the top three teams
will move on
and nekoma is going against fukurodani
in the semi-finals
fukudo dani's ace bokedo seems to be in
the zone which is always bad news for
the other team
typically he is really good at cross
spikes but since nekoma's libero was
blocking most of his shots he started
using straight spikes
nekoma's five head kenma picked up on
him changing his strats so they adjust
to start shutting him down
they also have their unpredictable ace
lev who we see is definitely a work in
progress but is rapidly improving thanks
to kenmo's reluctant guidance
now you should remember that bokuto is a
wild card so when he's excelling at a
certain aspect of his game he'll
sometimes forget how to do everything
else
he gets to the point that he can't
remember how to do a proper cross spike
since he was focusing so much on his
straight spikes
keishi steps up to compensate for bokudo
being a bit of a dumbass and gets
fukurodani their win over nekomahi
this secures fukurodi a spot at
nationals along with the other finalists
team
itachiyama institute nicoma isn't quite
out of it yet because the top three
teams are going so they have to play
against no heavy academy for third place
and the last spot at nationals
the no heavy captain suguru daisho is
the third year dick who constantly
antagonizes everybody
it gets to be 21-19 when lev starts to
step it up but
on the same play nekoma's libero mori
suke gets injured ova2
when you get a flashback of morisuke and
tetsuro when they first meet there is a
lot of friction between the two because
they are basically polar opposites
the only thing the two could ever agree
on is their dream to win nationals
but anyways back to the match yuki
shibayama is sent to replace morisuke
and everybody rallies around kenmon to
win the first set the no heavy ace
kazuma numai
comes in to turn things around when it
looks like nekima is about to score he
purposely positions himself to block the
ref's sight making it look like it was
out this is all a part of the team's
strategy to win by any means necessary
even if it's a little shady
despite their piddly-ass tactics lev and
yuki sync up and managed to
grab the winning point securing third
place and nekoma's spot at nationals
this is also another stepping stone for
lev because he's starting to learn how
teams work together making him an even
bigger threat
in the last couple of scenes we see that
in the finals itachiyama institute ended
up beating fukurodani academy making
them the first seed
and with those out of the way we can now
get into episode one we get a refresher
that kagiyama was invited to the youth
training camp the same that wakatoshi
was invited to when he was younger
this means that two years from now he
could get picked as one of the
under-19 representatives to compete
against the world
it's going to be five days long and
happens right before the spring
tournament in
january which is nationals there is also
going to be a special training camp for
promising rookies in the miyagi
prefecture this is an attempt to level
up miyagi prefecture's volleyball skills
as a whole
tsukushima was the only first year to be
invited though hinata is really bothered
by the fact that he didn't get invited
anywhere and is weighing on his mental
jump ahead just a bit where we see that
hinata has tagged along with tsukushima
to shirutorizawa high in order to attend
the camp without permission
he gets scolded by his coaches for being
a [ __ ] idiot and going to a camp that
he wasn't even invited to
luckily shiratorizawa's thick guy brad
coach steps in to say that he doesn't
mind if he's out of stays
over to kagayama who arrives at his camp
and meets
saksaki kiyumi the ace from tokyo's
first seat itachi yama institute
nothing really comes from that though
and then we jump back over to hinata who
finds out that washi joe is skeptical
that hinata will be useless without
kagayama since kagayama isn't there to
carry him he gives hinata the option of
going home or being the ball boy but he
can't play
this doesn't discourage he nodded though
so he sticks around to be the ball boy
[Music]
episode on the first day hinata fulfills
his role as ball boy while the others
practice
you can tell that he's eager to play and
we see that he feels like he's starting
to fall behind
everybody else the next day he is
repeatedly schooled by everybody and
then he goes back to be ball boy again
today's a little different though
because the [ __ ] of torizawa third years
and alumni including wakatoshi and tendo
show up to play a practice match against
the camp participants
and as one would expect the camp members
get smashed two sets in a row by the
upperclassmen
episode three while watching the
practice matches hinata tries observing
the players to learn about what makes
them so strong
he notices one player using a subtle
movement that he remembers is called a
split step to reset his form and propel
himself to where he needs to be hinata
tries implementing this while retrieving
the balls and while it works he gets
cracked in the face
after practice is done some of the
players stick around to play some more
and hinata continues working as the ball
boy in order to perfect the timing on
his split step we see the other katasuno
boys are hard at work as well as they
lose a practice match to another team
because most of their key players are
missing
again hinata is ball boy but his
movements are now a lot more thought
out instead of being purely instinctual
episode
iv tsukushima asks sinata to practice
blocking with him and some of the other
players after practice
hinata thinks that he is trying to give
him a chance to play but it's revealed
that tsukushima wants to play against
hinata
because he is a spiker that can actually
see the blockers and give him a
challenge
of course fukushima is never going to
say that cause he's a dick who doesn't
like to give compliments
kagayama to no one's surprise is syncing
up well with the others and his camp and
proves that he is more than capable
of keeping up with all of them there are
a couple of players that stand out
though including korrai hoshioumi
hoshiyumi is much like hinata and the
little giant in the sense that he is
very short but is still
one of the best players at the camp we
also meet another threat
in the second year setter mia atsumu who
causes friction with kagayama calling
him a goody two shoes
anyways back on over to hinata where the
guys are doing 2v2 matches
one of the players you die yakuzawa is
getting really discouraged
and ends up saying that he wishes hinata
was invited instead of him
he not a scolds him for being ungrateful
for the opportunity and then gives him
some advice on how to take it easy which
improves his performance episode 5.
we see that goody two-shoes comment
makes kagiyama reflect on being the
tyrant king and it starts to affect his
play
meanwhile at hinata's camp the
upperclassmen come back for another
skirmish with the guys
hinata tries learning everything he can
from the other players including
wakatoshi
kagiyama manages to snap out of his funk
and starts playing like himself again
after practice he asks mia what he meant
when he called him a goody two two-shoes
he just responds to that kagiyama is
serious honest and an all-around good
kid
which is pretty vague and doesn't
[ __ ] help the camp comes to an end
and everybody parts ways until they meet
again
at nationals hinata's camp ends also and
we see kagiyama's old teammate hajime
asking about kagiyama and seems to have
gotten over him being the tyrant king
when they play together
episode 6. the gang is all reunited
after the camps and work on their serves
where hinata shows off his new split
step move
we also see kagiyama give hinata tips on
how to jump higher by shifting his
weight to different parts of his feet
which is what hoshi umi was doing
dante tech then arrives for a practice
match where they show that their iron
wall defense is as good as ever they
continuously read and block kagayama
sets which gets him pumped up to be
getting to play against so many strong
teams
ye episode 7 during one of the plays
kagiyama gets kind of annoyed and says
that nishinoya was in the way of the
back attackers
normally nobody ever has anything really
bad to say to nishinoya and certainly
not like that
ever since he's gotten back from camp
kagayama has been a little bit more
sinister and everybody seems to be
picking up on it things start to get
even more tense when he starts giving
tsukushima orders also
the big teddy bear asahi is next on
kagayama's hit list when he snaps on him
for missing an easy point that costs
them the first set
fukushima being the confrontational dick
he is makes a comment about this being
the return of the king but when kagayama
goes to apologize hinata stops him he
says that kagayama should voice what
he's thinking and that if him or the
others don't like it then just don't
listen forehead
everyone points out that it's really
more about how he delivers the criticism
kagiyama seems to be trying to find a
middle ground between the king and goody
two-shoes where he can speak his mind
without pissing everybody off
he also decides to not use his skill to
compensate for spiker's bad habits and
instead force them to spike correctly
which is what he does with tsukushima
this doesn't really work out since they
aren't exactly used to this style and
they end up losing the second set also
everyone can see that the communication
is in the middle of an evolution with
all of the players learning the proper
ways to give and receive feedback with
kagiyama
episode 8 god asuno manages to win the
third set thanks to hinata drawing so
much attention from the blockers
creating openings for the others
we also see kagiyama getting more
conscientious of how other players are
doing like tsukushima getting really
tired and learning how to play around
that we get another scene of hinata's
instincts being improved and how he's
able to now bait blockers to him more
effectively
asahi shows a lot more confidence in the
face of the iron wall which used to
intimidate him and was also the reason
he quit in the prior seasons
he uses the newfound confidence to score
the winning point giving them
their final win in the practice matches
episode 9.
on new year's day the katasuna
upperclassmen seem a little on edge but
a visit to a shrine helps them get in
the right mindset for nationals the
filler content continues as the night
before
the tournament rolls around and everyone
is dealing with their nerves for the big
day in different ways
when they arrive for the first day
kagayama reconvenes with some of the
players from his training camp we also
get the reunion of katasuno with their
rivals in nekoma high and fukurodani
right before all of the teams make their
entrance to finally get things underway
episode 10. the team travels to another
local gym to get warmed up while the
other matches are going on
when they return hinata realizes that he
had lost his bag
so his shoes are missing his phone was
also in the bag so when they call it a
kid answers and explains that he grabs
hinata's bag by accident the kid and his
mom agree to wait at the gym so kyoko
runs down there with the kids bag
in order to make the exchange while this
is going on we get some backstory on
kyoko who used to be on the track team
before she joined as manager of the
volleyball team
her riot ends up leaving so she has to
rely on her speed instead to get her
back
just in time to get hinata his shoes
their first match is against
subakihata where they fall behind early
on because kagayama needs some time to
find his groove in the match
things are still looking rough with
kagiyama's play so tarashi makes an
early substitution to give him a chance
to reset
this works out as kagiyama comes online
and hinata nails their first quick of
the tournament
episode 11. it's not just kagiyama
making his mark but tsukushima is
exerting a lot of pressure onto the
attackers as well
hinata is also relying less on his
instincts and actually reading the
players to see where the ball will go
leading to some clutch saves it's still
a bit of a work in progress
because the ball is just bouncing off
his chest or face when he does it but
the thought is there sad character
nobody cares about kinoshita comes in to
[ __ ] up a serve and then is immediately
benched again
on match point in the first set tsubaki
had his pinch server himekawa chokes his
underhand serve pretty badly nailing his
teammate in the back of the head and
gifting the first set to katasuno this
just goes to show that every team has a
useless yamaguchi
his redemption arc ensues in the second
set where katasuno is leading but hime
cow was unorthodox underhand serves gets
them some easy points and the lead
kodasuno brings it to match point for
the second set and sugawata is subbed in
a long rally ensues and eventually asahi
is the one to put it away ending the set
and the match
with katasunu as the winners
episode 12. we get a quick look at
fukurodani whose drama queen ace is
already off his game because he wanted
to play in the main
arena instead of the subarena with their
match over katasuna heads over to watch
nekoma play where they take an early win
against kyokawa
back to fukurodani who try to keep the
ball from their ace until his mental has
recovered
luckily keiji is still a bit of a bocado
whisperer and he gets his ace back
online leading to their first win
also hinata has his first run in with
hoshioumi
and it instantly turns into a bit of a
rivalry when they watch one of his games
though it's clear that he is a step
above hinata as
him and the kama medai high school team
make quick work of their opponents
in the last scene we see that ryonosuke
might be the first one to end katasuna's
long female drought when his childhood
friend kanika ahmanai starts sending him
some signals
yeah episode 13. we get a short
flashback of how rio nosque was the one
that introduced kanika to volleyball and
gave her more confidence because she was
self-conscious about her tall height
for katasuno second match they are going
up against the second place
team from this year's inter-high
tournament inarizaki high school who are
also the favorites to win the whole
tournament
their top scorer number four ojira iran
is like bokuto being just outside the
top three hitters in japan
the middle blocker is number ten tsuna
rintaro who is a lot shorter than most
middle blockers but his instincts make
up for that these are two of their big
guns but the last major threat they need
to keep in mind is
mia who is the setter that called
kagiyama a goody two-shoes at their camp
it's not just his setting that makes him
a threat because he is also well known
for his serves doing both
insane spike serves as well as jump
float serves
we get some more fila content when
konica and ryonosuke end up alone
together and she almost confesses to him
when her cousin walks up to cockblock
him ryannosuke
obviously fears that this is her
boyfriend so he bolts leaving her heart
broken
while practicing they learn that mia's
twin brother osamu
had to sit out the finals for the
qualifier because he wasn't feeling a
hundred percent now he's back though so
that's just one more thing that they
have to keep in mind during their match
ganuka clears out the cousin
misunderstanding but they are both too
focused on their upcoming games so
neither of them pulls the trigger just
yet their second match gets underway
where kia gets an early lead with his
serves while asahi messes up his
this is because the crowd is being kind
of bm they are completely quiet while
mia serves but when katasuno goes to
serve they start booing them hinata then
gets the perfect setup to score in the
last scene but is too focused on his
jump and forgot to actually hit the ball
it's still enough to warrant an
immediate reaction from mia andy
narazaki though realizing that he's a
potential threat i'm gonna be doing the
future seasons and you can find that in
the left side whenever i'm finished with
it or you can check out all of the
haikyuu recaps in the playlist on the
right side you can also find the links
in the description below and the only
thing i hate more than intros
is outros